[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
what's a Prof how you doing Martin I'm
very well and you I beat you to
it now we carrying on and carrying on
and it's not a never- Ending Story yes
we're talking about the stone of
stumbling
and Martin this Stone has been a stone
of stumbling ever since there was a
rebellion in heaven yeah so it's even
before this Earth was created it was a
stone of
stumbling and imagine how many angels
stumbled over that stone right a third
and that's probably billions that's
billions now Martin since it's been such
a stone of stumbling and still is a
stone of stumbling I think we need to
pray yeah let
pray our heavenly father thank you thank
you for the stone that we can put all
our faith in help us to discover who and
what it is and that we cannot reject it
help our viewers and us with the holy
spirit's
Enlightenment and help us to understand
how important this is in Jesus name amen
amen in Matthew
21:42 Jesus said
did you never read in the scriptures the
stone which the builders rejected the
same is become the head of the corner
this is the Lord's doing it is marvelous
in our
eyes Martin this Stone of stumbling is
is Jesus of course they rejected him
then and the devil is
hellbent to get Humanity to reject him
in every age yeah particularly in our
age yes
and the Bible says the Gates of Hell
will not Prevail against the fact that
he is the rock yeah the stone of
stumbling not Peter no
he this is a very important subject and
it's a very complex subject because so
many people are deceived mhm and when we
talk about these things it might
sound well it might sound harsh because
you are saying that everybody that
doesn't include Jesus in the
formula is basically with the Antichrist
yes and basically
lost yes of course God looks at the
individual heart and he takes into
account the background and the knowledge
of the person and the light that and the
light that he has received so we don't
judge who is going to heaven or who is
not going to heaven as
individuals but we're looking at systems
correct
systems so let's let's jump right into
this there's a quote from the review and
Herald the death of Jesus Christ for the
Redemption of man lifts the veil and
reflects a flood of light back hundreds
of years upon the whole institution of
the Jewish system of religion without
the death of Christ all this system was
meaningless so the entire
typology the entire ceremonial law you
all the sacrifices everything pointed to
one thing and if you take Christ out of
the equation then it becomes a ceremony
and a ritual which is useless that's
actually what happened yes so without
the death of Christ the whole system is
is meaningless the Jews reject Christ
and therefore the whole system of
religion is to them indefinite
unexplainable and uncertain we're
talking about the nation mhm we're not
talking about individuals because there
will be individuals that will accept the
stone of stumbling yes they attach as
much importance to shadowy ceremonies of
types which have met their antitype as
they do to the law of ten Commandments
which was not a shadow but a reality as
enduring as the Throne of Jehovah the
death of Christ elevates the Jewish
system of types and ordinances showing
that they were of divine appointment and
for the purpose of keeping faith alive
in the hearts of his people they were
important yeah but type has met
antitype now I just want to read to you
what Micah says Martin Micah chapter
6 wherewith shall I come before the Lord
and bow myself before the high God shall
I come before him with burnt offerings
with carves of a year
old will the Lord be pleased with
thousands of rams or with 10,000 of
rivers of
oil shall I give my firstborn for my
transgression the fruit of my body for
the sin of my soul he has showed thee oh
man what is good and what does the Lord
require of thee but to do justly and to
love mercy and to walk humbly with thy
God so the sacrifice is of
importance
only as we contemplate Christ in it
that's it if your focus is gone from
Christ then all you're doing is a ritual
you have a ritual you have a ceremony
you have a liturgy but it is a
christless
liturgy now this is very new in the news
that uh
Rome and to some extent the Vatican
although they've never admitted having
the temple objects are willing to
return the vessels of the
temple that's breaking
news so recently shortly after the
Jewish High holidays the compelling
article was written here on Israel's 365
news about a leading Italian Member of
Parliament who doesn't want to be
identified who had a zoom meeting with
Jerusalem Affairs and Heritage Minister
amihai
eliahu the Italian MP stated that Italy
is in fact prepared to return the Lost
Temple vessels to Israel and that the
time is now to do
so the re action here in Israel has been
overwhelming could this be true the
article went on to go viral across many
faith-based Jewish and Christian
communities so you cannot separate the
two right the Christian and the other
especially now yes and the time is now
now whether this actually will take
place or not the fact of the matter it
is causing religious hype yeah the
article continues the good news in this
scenario is that the official Vatican
position currently is that they neither
confirm nor deny possessing any herodian
Temple objects like the golden manora
sacred tables altars Priestly garments
and the like so there was a
discussion with high officials and zoom
meetings and in the past they always
denied that they have them but the fact
of history is that there were were
carried to Rome yeah so if they still
exist they must exist somewhere yeah and
the most logical place is the Vatican
yeah now imagine for 2,000 years
practically less than 70 yeah they have
been hidden there if it is
so well this is what they claim this is
another article from the House of David
Ministries every day from my office I
see the Arch of Titus this is now this
Minister that is speaking to Israel yes
this politician who doesn't want to be
named for certain reasons it's hard to
miss it it's big and
impressive and everyone can see what's
displayed on it so here's the Arch of
Titus Jewish slaves carrying off the
Jewish temple implements into Exile and
if you look at that depiction there the
manora is very prominent yeah plus all
the other vessels 2,000 years ago we
defeated you this is Rome now we
destroyed your temple massacred your
people including crucifixions and exiled
the Jews throughout the world and I
suppose you deserved it the reason why
you would say that because history tells
us that the Jewish zealots killed many
many Roman soldiers yeah with the first
Siege and all the time they were like
terrorists and they they killed so many
that they got fed up
eventually and in the first Siege when
the Roman army withdrew the Jewish
zealots came from behind and killed many
Roman soldiers and that's why Titus came
back and destroyed
Rome so Jewish tradition itself says
this 2,000 years have passed and since
then you have undergone a deep change
you have returned to the land of Israel
and I suppose you also deserve to return
God promised that you would one day
return and that time is
now Martin I don't think they have a
comprehension of the typology no they
don't understand the part that your
house has been left to you desolate they
don't understand that part but this is
the reality of the
matter and if you take dispensationalism
this is what people believe yeah that
there will be two dispens s basically
one dealing with the Jews and one
dealing with the Christians but how the
two should meet if the stone of
stumbling is not included in both of
them it's impossible it's
impossible now here's an
article uh this is an academic article
it's published in
Academia and it just gives us the
backdrop I just took the abstract here
theopolitics in the Holy Land Christian
Zionism and Jewish religious
Zionism now mtin this is a misnomer it's
an
oxymoron a Christian
Zionism it's an oxymoron because Christ
cannot fit in that centers no so where
is he is in half yeah the other half
rejects him remember that Sanhedrin
member that said we will not accept
Christ we prefer to go to awit yeah and
we showed that video many times so it's
no point in putting it in again but the
Orthodox Jew does not accept Jesus
Christ no he and this will probably mean
that he still believes Christ must come
and that also negates Jesus again
correct they say Christians that man
said that son hedrin remember Christians
you may believe that it's Jesus but we
don't we don't believe that it's
Jesus and then Jewish religious Zionist
ISM so this article says this article
focus on the theopolitical core of us
Christian Zionism and Jewish religious
Zionism the political militancy
characterizing two
millenarian Messianic movements such as
Christian Zionism and Jewish religious
Zionism constitutes a still under
researched and under theorized aspect
that at present is Paramount
to address for its immediate and
long-term implications in the highly
sensitive and volatile Israeli
Palestinian issue in the US and Israel
domestic domain and in The Wider
International
Community they're asking the question
what is the relevance of this why is
there such a political hype why are they
willing to go to war why are they
willing to go through all of this
turmoil what is the issue it's because
it's linked to a religious view yeah and
the religious view is that the children
of Israel will return to the holy land
that the temple will be built but Jesus
said it will be desolate mhm the temple
was a place of offering yes it was a
place to bring everything together to
point towards Christ yes and once Christ
had come yeah and filled that Temple and
they rejected him and once the sacrifice
was brought because by one sacrifice he
has forever made
perfect there's no point in those
sacrifices therefore there's no point in
that Temple yes so how can Christians
and Jews at the same time strive towards
an ideal that is not biblical cannot
because that it actually is a slap in
Jesus's face yes if they want to rebuild
the Temple all right now we understand
that they have this
notion in fact Martin the facts of
History show that many of the Jews in
Israel
today are not descendants of the
original Jews but those that had been
converted to
Judaism so there's a lot of political
things that are going on here continues
to say although processes of the
sacralization of politics and
politization of religion have already
manifested themselves in countless forms
over past centuries Christian Zionism
and Jewish religious Zionism are
unprecedented phenomena given their
unique hybridized nature political
prominence and
Outreach mobilizing appeal amongst
Believers
organizational communicational skills
and degree of
institutionalization it is a massive
system where government and religions
are linked together in a political
religious system yeah that is willing to
be active militarily in order to
Implement to protect what they
believe and doesn't the bible say that
church and state will come together it
does and it not supposed to because
that's not biblical and this further is
it confined to the United States no no
no worldwide and because Israel is
involved anybody who jumps onto this
mindset will be involved whether they
live in Europe whether they live any
anywhere in any country in the world and
all eyes are focused on Jerusalem Y and
the stone of stumbling
Martin go
asde
okay there's another quote from the home
missionary the Savior has said he that
believeth on the son has everlasting
life and he that believeth not the sun
shall not see life that's pretty
straightforward yeah but the wrath of
God God abideth on him he says again and
this is life eternal that they might
Know Thee the only true God and Jesus
Christ whom thou has sent now we've
dealt with the Jews they reject Jesus as
the
Messiah and even if they are Messianic
Jews the Messiah that they are waiting
for is a national deliverer not God
coming to take his bride home yes and
not delivering you from the slavery of
sin no it's a national Deliverance now
Islam does exactly the same
thing Islam in fact is very intricately
involved because they both have the same
holy sights yeah so we continue with
this article muhammadanism has its
converts in many lands and its Advocates
deny the Divinity of Christ shall this
Faith be propagated and The Advocates of
Truth fail to manifest intense Zeal to
overthrow the error and teach men of the
pre-existence of the only savior of the
world oh how we need men who will search
and believe the word of God who will
present Jesus to the world in his Divine
and human nature declaring with power
and in demonstration of the spirit that
there is none other name under Heaven
given amongst men whereby we must be
saved
oh how we need believers who will now
present Christ in life and character who
will hold him up before the world as the
brightness of the father's Glory
proclaiming that God is love this
message is directly opposed to Judaism
in its modern
form and Islam because both reject the
stone of
stumbling now that doesn't mean that we
are
anti-islam
people no or anti-jewish
people we are not against the people no
we're against the system it has to be
exposed that's it because the Christian
system has got a rule and that is that
Jesus is the only way correct that's
God's Rule and we can talk about all the
other religions as well and they will
they will be offended yeah and we cannot
help that but we need the Zeal
to present Christ in his Divine and
human form because it's the only way to
be save Martin if you are on a road to
destruction and I say to you my friend
you're on the wrong
road you must take this road this is the
correct road it will lead you to the
correct Place do I become your enemy
that's how the world actually
unfortunately Works you're right but
it's not supposed to be like that now
this has been exposed long time ago the
Reformation exposed it
again this is Martin Luther writing the
Turk himself Martin where it says Turk
we would
today put in Islam yeah the Turk himself
who believes there is only one God who
has created all things permits Christ to
remain a prophet though he denies that
he is the only begotten true and natural
Son of God but I God be praised have
learned out of the Holy scriptures and
by experience in my trials Temptations
and fierce combats against the devil
that this article of Christ's humanity
is most sure and certain for nothing has
more or better help me in high spiritual
Temptations than my comfort in this that
Christ
the true Everlasting Son of God is our
flesh and bone as St Paul says to the
Ephesians chapter 5 we are members of
his body of his flesh and Bone he sth at
the right hand of God and makes
intercession for us when I take hold on
this Shield of Faith then I soon drive
away that Wicked one with all his fiery
DTS so even the Reformation told us
there is no other way yeah no other way
to be saved through Jesus Christ yeah in
fact I think they reestablished it very
clearly yes he continues to say God from
the beginning has held fth to this
article and powerfully defended the same
against all Heretics the pope and the
Turk afterwards confirmed it with many
miraculous signs so that all who have
opposed the same at last have been
brought to confusion and he's right the
stone of stumbling is still there well
and it's still a bone of contention or
actually a stone of contention yes
nothing has changed no but the fact that
we're still talking about it means that
the gates of hell did not Prevail
against amen
definitely but here is an article that
comes from a masonic Source it comes
from the Cano Valley
Lodge and uh it's an article that was
written in 20 2018 and it states a
remarkable connection of Freemasonry and
Israel now we've said this before but
here's now a masonic
Source giving us this history on
November 2
1917 balfor wrote a momentous letter to
the most influential Jewish leader in
Britain Lord Walter
Rothchild now of course this was
preceded and it also States this in the
article
uh by a discussion between Winston
Churchill and uh the the role players
involved this letter which began his
Majesty's government views with favor
The Establishment in Palestine of a
national home for the Jewish
people became the legal basis for the
partition of Palestine and establishment
of a Jewish state so M if there's a
partition then that's a two-state solu
ution now there are many articles in the
news these days that this war that is
taking place in Gaza actually
jeopardizes the two-state solution yeah
maybe they want Israel to be all one
again so that they
determine what the politics and the
religio political situation will be
whether it happens or not it's just
interesting that that was the original
idea
on November 19 1947 right before an
important vote in the United Nations on
the partition of Palestine viman flew to
Washington DC to Lobby American
president Harry Truman after a brief
meeting viman persuaded a conflicted
Truman to support the establishment of a
Jewish State and Truman proceeded to
pull out all the stops and heavily
lobbied numerous delegates to ensure
that the resolution favoring partition
received enough votes to pass and on
November 29 1947 with a vote of 33 in
favor 10 against and 13
exstension the UN resolution 181 became
the international basis for the
establishment of the modern state of
Israel and then they continued to say
that virtually all the role players
yeah involved were high Masons High
Masons so they're actually proud of it
exactly proud that's why they put it on
their their website yes so it's a
masonic state it is not a state that
comes from a Divine instruct ex that's
very important that people realize it's
not the Fulfillment of Bible prophecy no
it is a planned concoction correct all
right now Martin if that is the
case
then why is it there
mhm and if it is there then it must be a
counterfeit
yeah where does it emanate from we've
said many many times that this is a
Jesuit Counter Reformation
activity to sweep all the world into the
acceptance of a false religious
interpretation mhm namely that the
Antichrist will come in the future yes
in a Jewish rebuilt Temple and so the
heat is taken off of the papacy as the
true
Antichrist did the reformation identify
the papacy as the Antichrist 100%
100% does it fit all the biblical
criteria of Daniel and Revelation yes
can it be anything else no does the
Bible expand on this issue and tell us
that there are other possibilities of an
antichrist or is there only one
possibility only one possibility so
modern this must be a a false system MH
of interpretation that's it it's a
counterfeit once again by the master of
reversal all right and if you want to
bring all the religious systems
together and most of them or 99% of them
reject Jesus Christ as the
Messiah then you again reject the stone
of stumbling yeah okay as an article in
the Washington Post half of evangelicals
support Israel because they believe it
is important for fulfilling end time
prophecy God's promise to Abraham and
his descendants was for all
time that's true but if you are in
Christ you are Abraham's descendants
they forget that sentence they forget
that sentence Hebrews in Christ you are
the Seed of Abraham yes so Evangelical
attitudes towards Israel research study
shows that those who agree strongly that
Israel is important in this is well over
60% 60 seconds 2/3 that's
amazing but it's also worth picking out
another part of what Jeffrey said to CNN
Jerusalem is said is the Touchstone of
Prophecy that prophecy is the biblical
Prophecy of the return of Jesus Christ
and the beginning of the Rapture you see
so yeah is there confusion in that
completely is there going to be a
Rapture there's going to be a Rapture
when Jesus comes to fetch us that will
be the Rapture is there going to be a
secret Rapture no does the Bible speak
about the secret Rapture nothing nothing
as the the lightning is visitable from
the East to the West so will the coming
of the son of man be right so this
Rapture will be once when Jesus comes to
take his whole church his spiritual
Israel back to to him correct so Martin
it is
interesting that half of evangelicals
support Israel because they believe it
is important and then almost 80% agree
but they must must be many in the
Evangelical world that are confused yeah
and say how can it be that we should
have an alliance there and that this
this dichotomy of thinking should even
fit somehow into a prophetic
picture now if
Freemasonry was the instrument of
setting up this entire system in order
to fulfill a hypothetical prophetic
picture that is not biblical and to take
the place of the biblical
picture then how can we trust it here's
a quote from selected messages fraud
runs through all these secret
associations and none can be bound up
with them and be free men before God and
Heaven right that's true the model
nature is dragged down to that which God
pronounces unjust which is contrary to
his will and his Commandments one who
professes to love God May in these
associations be placed in positions
which are called honorable but in the
eyes of God he astonishing his honor as
a Christian and separating father and
far from the principles of righteousness
and true
Holiness he's perverting his powers that
have been purchased by the blood of
Jesus he's selling his soul for na
that's pretty strong language so after
reading this I think you must rethink if
you want to be part of any of these
secret societies yes or anything that
emanates from
them in the revelation of his righteous
judgments God will break up these
associations and when the Judgment shall
sit and the books be open there will be
revealed the UN christlikeness of the
whole
Confederacy those who choose to unite
with these secret societies are paying
homage to Idols as senseless and as
powerless to bless and save the soul as
are the gods of the Hindus there goes
another big religious system with a more
than a billion adherence exactly that's
also rejecting the stone if the stone is
not involved the building cannot fitly
be constructed right that's it so M it's
all about Jesus it's all about a choice
do we accept Jesus say the Savior who is
he is he like Islam says just another
Prophet mhm is he like uh the
Jewish Orthodox people believe an
impostor and they're waiting for someone
else yeah and even the Jesus that they
waiting for is just a national deliverer
and not God himself coming to take them
to heaven correct here's another quote
I was pointed to some who are in the
Great error of believing that it is
their duty to go to Old Jerusalem and
think they have a work to do there
before the Lord comes such a view is
calculated to take the mind and interest
from the present work of the Lord under
the message of the third
angel now we discussed the third Angel
right yeah righteousness by faith in
Verity is the essence of the third
Angels do not accept the mark of the
beast do not set accept the false system
of worship which places Sunday as your
sign of rest rather than the
Sabbath for those who think that they
are yet to go to Jerusalem will have
their minds there and their means will
be withheld from the course of present
truth to get themselves and and others
to
Jerusalem I saw that such a mission
would accomplish no real good that it
would take a long while to make a very
few of the Jews believe even in the
first Advent of Christ much more to
believe in the second
Advent I saw that Satan had greatly
deceived some in this thing and that
Souls all around them in this land could
be helped by them and led to the
Commandments of God but they were
leaving them to perish so by
concentrating on Jerusalem and what's
happening there souls are lost
because you're not preaching the gospel
to we mentioned this a few times there
mustn't be an especially no we have to
especially reach these people or
especially these people because then
you're going to neglect somebody else
does the message of the stone of
stumbling does that message need to go
to Islam yes does it need to go to
Judaism yes does it need to go to
Zionism
yes does it need to go to Hinduism
definitely and does it need to go to
confused Christianity yes because
they're looking at a place rather than
working on their hearts to prepare for
the coming of Christ that's it so
everybody it's not singling out anybody
now this comes from early writings I
also saw that old Jerusalem never would
be built
up does that mean the temple won't be
rebuilt no it can never be rebuilt why
should it not be rebuilt because like we
mentioned before then it shows how you
negate the Christ yes you want to
implement a system and ritual that
points to Christ but there's no Christ
in
it and it's a negation of the one
sacrifice that has forever made perfect
yeah all right and that Satan was doing
his utmost to lead the minds of the
children of the Lord into these things
now in the Gathering time to keep them
from throwing their whole interest into
the present work of the Lord and to
cause them to neglect the necessary
preparation for the day of the Lord we
have a message to preach and the message
is accept Jesus Christ as your personal
savior now he needs to be accepted these
religious systems reject him we cannot
be part of them
there's another quote Martin men and
women may study the will of God with
profit let young men and young women
while the due of Youth is upon them
begin to study the word of God which
expresses his
will the steps of Christ are certainly
marked out in the word go where they can
be found today do not seek to go back to
the land where Christ's feet trod ages
ago Christ says he that followeth me
shall not walk in in darkness but shall
have the light of life we can know far
more of Christ by following him step by
step in the work of redemption seeking
The Lost and the perishing than by
journeying to Old
Jerusalem Christ has taken his people
into his
church we should have highlighted that
yes we should have but actually we
should highlight this whole portion yes
it's very important we need to point
point out that out of that system
thousands of Jews came
into the Christian system right because
the Christian system was the Fulfillment
of their types and shadows yes so the
truth exists in true
Christianity which doesn't reject the
stone of stumbling yes so they the
church left this
system of rituals to become the body of
Christ yes because they understood the
meaning of the rituals and the
Fulfillment thereof that's why the
curtain was torn from top to bottom
because the old system was done away
with yeah he has swept away this is
Jesus every ceremony of the ancient type
he has given no Liberty to restore these
rights or to substitute anything that
will recall the old literal sacrifices
that's pretty clear yeah Martin so and
it's biblical that's it 100% just
because this person wrote it doesn't
make it unbiblical that's biblical yes
the lord requires of his people
spiritual sacrifices alone that's what I
read in Micah yes everything pertaining
to his worship is placed under the
superintendence of his holy spirit Jesus
said that the father would send the holy
spirit in his name to teach his
disciples all things and to bring all
things under the remembrance that he had
said unto them Martin when Paul went to
preach in a certain place and there were
people that had accepted Jesus but
didn't understand anything about the
Holy Spirit he asked them have you
received the Holy Spirit they said we've
never even heard of
him right yeah so Martin if the true
Spirit isn't working and you're being
pointed back to types and shadows then
it must be a foul spirit and an unclean
bird that is directing you in that
direction and making it all part of
Babylon again making it part of
Babylon the curse rests upon Jerusalem
the Lord has obliterated those things
which men would Worship in and about
Jerusalem yet many hold in reverence
literal objects in Palestine while they
neglect to behold Jesus as their
advocate in the the heaven of Heavens an
article in the review of Herald this is
so spoton that's it so this shows you
everybody is in up in arms and in a hype
because of the possibility of the temple
artifacts being able to go back to
Jerusalem and you forget about Jesus
forget about Jesus so what is it
important that we understand Jesus that
we understand his mission what's his
mission to save everybody that he died
for yeah does that include the Jew every
single person Does it include the
muhammadan Does it include the Hindu the
shaman whatever nature worshippers new
ages atheists anybody right Luke 16:16
and the law and the prophets were until
John
period they were until John the Baptist
that's it there they
stopped since that time the kingdom of
God is preached and every man presses
into it the law and the prophets were
until John if you're going to repeat
this and create it again you are
negating this verse in scripture
completely then you can just as well
take it out of the Bible Matthew 11:12
and from the days of John the Baptist
until now the Kingdom of Heaven
suffereth violence and the violent take
it by force have they taken it by force
yes how many people have been killed
Millions have the Gates of Hell
prevailed no it's still going it must be
the truth of course otherwise it would
be gone I mean how hard did they try how
hard has s Satan tried over the last
2,000 years to get rid of this it tried
to get rid of the Bible he tried to get
rid of true Christianity he mixed
paganism and Christianity he changed the
law of God he did everything in his
power to get comes up with new theories
to take the the the prophecies into the
future or than the past everything has
been he's thrown everything at it yes
and he's got a false
system that is to take the place of true
Christianity and it's a goly
GOP listen it doesn't fit together acts
28:31 preaching the kingdom of God and
teaching those things which concern the
Lord Jesus Christ with all confidence no
man forbidding him
that's our mission that's our mission
everything else is eyewash
yeah quoting Psalms 2:8 ask of me and I
shall give ye the Heathen for thine
inheritance and the uttermost parts of
the Earth for thy possession it's
talking about Jesus Christ MH he was
going to take the whole world into his
possession not concentrate on one little
Nation Thou shalt break them with a rod
of iron Thou shalt Dash them in pieces
like a pot's vessel be wise now
therefore oh ye Kings be instructed ye
judges of the earth serve the Lord with
fear and rejoice with trembling kiss the
son lest he be angry and you perish from
the way when his wrath is kindled but a
little blessed are they that put their
trust in him have they no
unfortunately everybody is rejecting him
that's Old Testament Martin we've read
it many times that was a prophecy that's
it they've rejected him again Mark 1:15
and saying the time is fulfilled and the
kingdom of God is at hand repent and
believe the gospel the law and the
prophets were until John John Mark 4:11
and he said unto them unto you it is
given to know the mystery of the kingdom
of God but unto them that are without
all these things are done in Parables
they're still in Parables Martin they
don't get
no and God is still
trying different ways of bringing it to
everybody to understand it yes they
still reject it I love this backdrop
that we have
here Stone of stumbling the way the
truth the life he writing in the sand I
think he's still writing in the sand and
saying w't you please realize what your
problem is your problem is your sinful
heart yeah
don't you think so I agree 100% Psalms
110 the Lord has sworn and will not
repent thou art a priest Forever After
the order of meis EDC can you take it
away this priesthood no
God was before and he will be forever so
the whole christless
Confederacy will be taken away it will
be like dust when that rock strikes the
feet of the Statue of
Daniel Martin Luther says the Lord swear
and will not repent thou art a priest
this is the most glorious sentence in
the whole
Psalms where God claims unto us that
this Christ shall be our Bishop and high
priest who without ceasing shall make
intercession for those that are his and
none others besides him it shall be
neither Caiaphas nor anas Peter Paul nor
the Pope
but Christ only Christ therefore let us
take refuge in him that's the gospel
that's very well
put it's amazing the Insight that these
reformers
have and the adherence
to this individual they call themselves
lutherans do they still believe well
maybe there's individuals that still
believe but as a church a
denomination they don't believe it
anymore but if they don't believe it
then you have to come out of her my
people and join those that keep the
Commandments and have the faith of Jesus
that's it all right who's this Jesus who
is the stone of
stumbling he was equal with God infinite
and omnipotent he is the Eternal
self-existent son mhm that makes him God
right cannot be any other he was from
Everlasting while God's word speaks of
the humanity of Christ when upon the
Earth it also speaks decidedly regarding
his
pre-existence the word existed as a
Divine being even as the Eternal Son of
God in Union and Oneness with his father
from Everlasting he was the mediator of
the Covenant the one in whom all nations
of the earth both Jews and Gentiles if
they accepted him were to be blessed the
word was with God and the Word was God
before men or Angels were created the
word was with God and was God is that
biblical that's biblical and very clear
does the Jehovah's Witness Bible change
that to reduce Christ to a created being
yeah in Christ is Life original
unborrowed underived he that has the son
has life 1 John 512 the Divinity of
Christ is the believer's Assurance of
eternal life that's so important I think
it needs to be repeated at some
stage well the Divinity of Christ is the
believer's Assurance of eternal life I
believe it and I wish everybody would
believe it the Jew and the
Gentile and to us he says I am the Good
Shepherd I am the living bread I am the
way the truth and the life I am the
Assurance of every promise I am Be not
Afraid God With Us is the shity of our
deliverance from sin comes from the
faith I live by m are these statements
all in the Bible yes is Jesus the I am
then he is
yve 1 Timothy 3:16 and without
controversy great is the mystery of
godliness God was manifest In the Flesh
justified in the spirit seen of angels
preached unto the Gentiles believed on
in the world received up into the glory
this is a
summary of The Plan of
Salvation do modern manuscripts change
this unfortunately yes mod is he a stone
of stumbling yes even in the Christian
church it's
amazing another quote from the faith I
live by Christ was one with the father
yet he was willing to step down from the
exaltation of one who was equal with God
that he might accomplish his purpose of
love for the Fallen race he became bone
of our bone and flesh of our flesh how
wide is the contrast between the
Divinity of Christ and the helpless
infant in bethlehem's manger how can we
span the distance between the Mighty God
and a helpless child did Satan try to
kill that helpless child yes did he
succeed no no and yet the creator of the
of Worlds he in whom was the fullness of
the godhead bily was manifest in the
helpless bab in the
manger far higher than any of the Angels
equal with the father in dignity and
glory and yet wearing the Garb of
humanity Divinity and Humanity were
mysteriously combined and man and God
became one do the religious systems
fight against this oh for sure like I
mentioned even in Christianity they want
to make Jesus less than God Eternal
himself I have a a copy of a particular
Quran which in the forward has
such derogatory statements about the
Divinity of Christ that you
shudder where they claim that everybody
who believes in the Divinity of Christ
will will be
destroyed Martin is he a bone of
contention is he still the stone of
stumbling yeah another quote from the
signs of the time Christ shows them that
although they might reckon his life to
be less than 50 Years yet his Divine
Life could not be reckoned by human
computation the existence of Christ
before his Incarnation is not measured
by
figures life or original unborrowed
underived I said I would repeat it the
Divinity of Christ is the believer's
Assurance of eternal life you either
have him or you don't that's it and it's
amazing how Satan tries with every arrow
of his to get your confidence in his
divinity shut
it and then you don't have anything to
stand on because you believe actually in
something or you make it a whole so boox
to stand on and it again takes you away
from the from Jesus there's another
quote from counsels to parents everyone
that is of the truth Christ declares
heareth my voice in other words they
follow him right do these religions
systems hear the voice no no so they're
not of the truth having stood in the
councils of God having dwelt in the
Everlasting Heights of the sanctuary all
elements of Truth were in him and of him
he was one with God it means more than
finite Minds can comprehend to present
in every missionary effort Christ and
him
crucified he was wounded for our
transgression he was bruised for our
iniquities the CH chastisement of our
peace was upon him with his stripes we
are healed Isaiah
53:5 I was once debating with an
orthodox Jew about this statement he got
so
angry when I pointed out that this can
only apply to Jesus Christ no they apply
it to the Jewish Nation yeah isn't
amazing whenever you take the Bible and
you show to something towards Jesus even
him being God or all of this people get
really angry yes there's a lot of
animosity so whose animosity are they
reflecting the devil you're right Martin
he has made him to be sin for us who
knew no sin that we might be made the
righteousness of God in him quoting two
Corinthians Christ crucified for our
sins Christ risen from the dead Christ
ascended on high as our
intercessor this is the sign sence of
Salvation that we need to learn and
teach this is to be the burden of our
work Martin if we have a christless
religion we have a religion that leads
nowhere no and it's also it's always
centered on self yes he's the world's
Redeemer he stands between Satan and
every soul for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son and
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have
have eternal life the belt of Truth G
your loins you need this
truth Martin if you don't have the belt
of
truth then your trousers fall down yes
and you are naked you don't have the
righteousness of Christ and those who
lay their sins upon Christ through faith
in his righteousness will come off
Victorious as our mediator Jesus was
fully able to accomplish this work of
redemption but oh it what a price the
sinless Son of God was condemned for the
sin in which he had no part in order
that Sinners through repentance and
Faith might be justified by the
righteousness of Christ in which he had
no personal Merit the sins of everyone
who has lived upon the Earth were laid
upon Christ testifying to the fact that
no one need be a loser in the conflict
with Satan provision has been made that
all may lay hold of his strength of him
who will save to the uttermost all who
come unto God by him these are what some
of the most beautiful statements that
you can possibly read it shows you it's
an open invitation yes to every single
person on Earth you have to accept the
righteousness of
Christ and the war against this
statement is just
unbelievable if you think about the
whole construct of the Inquisition was
to to war against this statement yeah
because the church and the church will
choose and the pope yeah you have to
take their stand and still he is the the
leader of the religious world and
everybody wonders after to him everybody
wonders after to him this is Martin
Luther again and uh he's talking about
this verse for God who commanded the
light to shine out of Darkness has
shined in our hearts to give the light
of the knowledge of the glory of God in
the face of Jesus Christ if you want to
find out about the glory the character
of God then look at the face of Jesus
Christ
yeah Martin Luther says the chief lesson
and study in Divinity is that we learn
well and rightly to know Christ who is
therein very graciously pictured forth
unto us we take pains to conciliate the
Good Will and friendship of
men that that so they may show us
favorable countenance how much the more
ought we to conciliate our lord Jesus
that so he may be gracious unto us and
Peter says grow up in the knowledge of
Jesus Christ and that compassionate Lord
and Master whom all should learn to know
him only out of the scriptures where he
says search the scriptures for they do
testify of me so if they reject him have
they really thoroughly search the
scriptures no and when you do thoroughly
search the scriptures it must be
unselfish so you don't have a
preconceived selfish motive kiss the sun
it comes from Psalms it's the Old
Testament because the yeah let us make
man in our image that's plural he was
talking to Jesus they claim now he was
talking to the angels that's ridiculous
because the angels why yeah it doesn't
even make sense no Martin Luther has
some wonderful things to say and I know
I'm I'm laboring the fact but the fact
has to be labored yeah because the whole
world rejects it you know what people
don't get time to read so this is the
time you can read to let's read it he
says if Christ be not God then neither
the father nor the Holy Ghost is God for
our article of faith speaks thus Christ
is God with the father and the Holy
Ghost has he now got the eye of the
entire religious World on him yes yes
many there are who talk much of the
godhead of Christ as the pope and others
but they discourse thereof as a blind
man speaks of colors they haven't got a
clue therefore when I hear Christ speak
and say come to me all ye that are weary
and heavy laden and I will give you rest
then do I believe steadfastly that the
whole godhead speaks in an undivided and
unseparated
substance wherefore anyone that preaches
a God to me that did not die for me on
the cross I will not receive this
God how do you feel about that I agree
100% what yeah you are at loggerheads
with the entire religious world I
decided that I will do what God asks and
not what the world expects so you want
to say here I stand I can do no other
I'll follow in Martin's footsteps he
continues he says the holy scriptures
especially St Paul everywhere ascribe
unto Christ that which he gives to the
father namely the Divine Almighty power
so that he can give Grace and peace of
conscience forgiveness of sins life
victory over sin death and the devil now
unless St Paul would Rob God of his
honor and give it to to another that is
not God he dared not describe such
properties and attributes to Christ if
he were not true
God you can't say he gives Grace and
forgiveness of sins and victory over the
devil if he's not God no and Jesus could
not accept worship if he was not God let
alone Thomas falling at his feet and
saying my Lord and my
God and then he quotes Isaiah and he
says and God himself says I will not
give my glory to another and indeed no
man can give that to another which he
has not for
himself Jesus died on the cross because
it became apparent to everybody that he
claimed to be God correct but he proved
it through the resurrection
yes but seeing Christ gives Grace and
peace the Holy Ghost also and redeems
from the power of the devil sin and
death
so is it most sure that he has an
endless immeasurable Almighty power
equal with the father we must think of
no other God than
Christ that is a stone of stumbling M
no that he has an endless immeasurable
Almighty power equal with the father we
must think of no other God than Christ
that God which speaks not out of
Christ's mouth is not not God God in the
Old Testament bound himself to the
throne of grace there was the place
where he would hear so long as the
policy and government of Moses stood and
flourished in like manner he will still
hear no man or human creature but only
through
Christ would you agree with that
statement 100% it's a very powerful
statement it it causes a big division
yes because that's the only way if he is
the only way then he will hear through
nobody's mouth but
Christ a number of the Jews ran to and
fro from burning incense and offering
here and there and seeking God in
various places not regarding the
Tabernacle so it goes now we seek God
everywhere but not seeking him in Christ
we find him
nowhere Martin what does that do to the
religious systems it puts all of them at
a
loss so Martin Luther had amazing
Insight now I accepted
Christ as a consequence of the word long
before I read these statements yeah long
before this is the first time I've read
this these statements though this
statement didn't influence me in my
thinking at all no but it confirms me in
my thinking it confirms me I I agree
with this because my thinking was the
same as this through studying the Bible
now let's read something
sad something very sad where Martin
Luther again is right but unfortunately
he gets something wrong okay rather sad
Luther but here your hopes are
dashed but then what a crafty and mighty
Spirit the devil must be who can aright
and with his fiery dots draw the hearts
of good and godly people from this
excelling comfort and make them
entertain other cognit of Christ that he
is not the high priest but complains of
them to God that he is not the bishop of
their souls but a Stern and angry judge
the devil has tried everything to
misrepresent the character of
Christ the lord said to Christ rule in
the midst of thine enemies on the the
other hand the devil claims to be Prince
and God of the world he is therefore the
sworn enemy of Jesus Christ and of his
word and of those who follow that word
sincerely and without
guile so if you follow the word are you
in trouble you are in between the
conflict of The of Christ and Satan and
that once again you cannot be in the
middle you're going to be crushed you
have to accept one or the other and then
he continued is and he says is
impossible for Jesus Christ and the
devil ever to remain under the same roof
that's what you just
said the one must yield to the other the
devil to Christ the Jew and the apostles
were for a while under the same roof and
the Jews plagued and persecuted the
apostles and their followers but after a
while were themselves Thrust out by the
Romans as little can the Luther and the
papist hold together one party must
yield and by the blessing and Aid of God
this will be the
papist sorry Martin Luther to tell you
500 years after the
event that the lutherans have
capitulated and are sitting in
ecumenical councils and have signed the
joint Declaration on
justification so your followers have
yielded as an institution Martin Luther
yes but there are individuals in your
church that you raised up on this Earth
that will accept that Jesus Christ is
the the way the truth and the life the
only the only one and will separate from
all of these
institutions that have made him less
than what he is Imagine Martin taking a
mere man and elevating his authority it
above that of Jesus Christ isn't that in
a front it is but the other the other
religions do it with self they put you
as we've seen that in the previous
lecture you are God you are Divine
unbelievable there's another quote from
Martin Luther the WTH is fierce and
devouring which the devil has against
the Son of God and against mankind I
beheld one wants a wolf tearing
sheep when the wolf comes into the sheep
fold he eats not any until he has killed
all and then he begins to eat thinking
to devour all even so it is with the
devil I have now thinks he taken Hold On
Christ and in time I will also snap up
his
disciples but the devil's Folly is that
he sees not he has to do with the Son of
God he knows not not that in the end it
will be his Bane it will come to pass
that the devil must be afraid of a child
in the
Cradle for when he but hears the name of
Jesus uttered in true faith and he
cannot stay the devil would rather run
through the fire than stay with where
Christ is therefore it is justly said
the seed of the woman shall crush the
Serpent's head that he can neither abide
or hear or see Jesus Christ
Martin Christ is going to be the
Victor why not choose the size of the
side of the Victor you know what he has
already actually won yes he already had
the victory over Satan in the Wilderness
at the cross and he's just coming to
fetch his own yes he he conquered him in
the wilderness and he paid the price for
our sins at the cross both of those are
denied yeah by the EST lished systems of
religion and Martin this is what we need
to understand if we don't cling to
Christ we have a futile
religion modern Luther continues nothing
is more sure than this he that does not
take hold on Christ by faith and comfort
himself herein that Christ is made a
curse for him remains under the
curse there goes the whole of
Catholicism that's it so if you don't
let Christ carry your sins you're going
to carry it yourself yes that's why they
have a Purgatory you can pay for it and
only the pope can relieve you of the
punishment this is such a ridiculous
system and it totally negates the
biblical
story The More We labor by works to
obtain Grace the less we know how to
take hold on Christ for where he is not
known and comprehended by faith there is
is not to be expected either advice help
or Comfort though we torment ourselves
to death and he did yeah before he
recognized that Christ was his savior he
chastised himself yeah there's another
source this is from heaven with love the
Jewish leaders were fixed in a rut of
Ceremonies and traditions their hearts
had become like dried up win skins
satisfied with a legal religion it was
impossible for them to become the
depositories of Living Truth it was
impossible and it still
is
true they did not desire that a new
element should be brought into their
religion the faith that works by love
and purifies the soul could find no
place for Union with the religion of the
Pharisees made up of Ceremonies and
injunctions of men to unite the
teachings of Jesus with his established
religion would be vain the vital truth
of God like wine would burst the old
decaying bottles of the pharisaical
tradition that's very well put it's
brilliant that is still true today yes
any
tradition must go it must go and if you
do not accept Jesus when they rejected
him what they were left with his
ceremonies and traditions christless
ceremonies and traditions as useless to
save as the god of the Hindus you know
how many people are stuck in Babylon
because of tradition yes because their
fathers were in that church or their
fathers were part of it and their family
we must be very wary of
tradition now tradition does it negate
the law of God yes didn't Jesus say in
vain you worship me teaching for
doctrines the Commandments of when
setting aside the law of God for your
Traditions so not only do they reject
Christ as their savior they reject his
system of government they reject his law
and when you reject Christ you have no
Savior and when you reject his law then
you are a sinner so if you accept Christ
but you don't accept his law then you
still on the same side as people
rejecting Christ because it cannot be
separated the devil has got his bread
buttered on both
sides a legal religion can never lead
souls to Christ is this in harmony with
what Martin Luther said
yes for it is a Loveless christless
religion fasting or prayer that is
actuated by a self-justifying spirit is
an abomination in the sight of God very
strong words yeah but we read it in
Micah same the solemn assembly for
worship the round of religious
ceremonies the external humiliation the
imposing sacrifice Proclaim that the
doer of these things regards himself as
righteous as a title to heaven but it is
all a deception our own Works can never
purchase salvation you can offer goats
and sheep and Bullocks as much as you
like you can build temples and glorify
ceremonies it's meaningless that's it
without Christ this means nothing man
must be emptied of self before before he
can be in the fullest sense a believer
in Jesus when self is renounced then the
Lord can make man a new creature new
bottles can contain the new wine the
love of Christ will animate the believer
with new life in him who looks unto the
author and finisher of our faith the C
character of Christ will be
manifest Martin the character of Christ
was I have come to do thy will oh God it
is written of me in the
book so Martin let me ask you a question
does the world need a true Revival yes
not a Revival built on hype and temples
and Jerusalem's and Israel and Zionism
and
frell and whatever no a Biblical Revival
okay so we need a Revival of true Faith
this comes from this great source the
great
controversy the Apostle Paul declares
that all that will live Godly in Jesus
Christ or in Christ Jesus shall suffer
persecution if you speak the truth you
will be an enemy of humanity that's it
and the leading figure will be the pope
yeah why is it then that persecution
seems in a great degree to Slumber the
only reason is that the church has
conformed to the world's standard and
therefore awakens no
opposition the religion which is current
in our day is not of the pure and holy
character that marked the Christian
faith in the days of Christ and his
apostles
it is only because of the spirit of
compromise with sin because the great
truths of the word of God are so
indifferently regarded because there is
so little vital godliness in the church
that Christianity is apparently so
popular with the
world let there be a Revival of faith
and power of the early church and the
spirit of persecution will be revived
and the fires of persecution will be re
rekindled why was Steven stoned because
he said Christ is the only way why was
Peter put in prison
same and why was Paul beheaded because
of exactly those
things Revelation 17:2 and 13 and the 10
horns which thou sawest are 10 Kings
which received no Kingdom as yet but
received power as kings one hour with
the
Beast so the nations of the world will
be in harmony with the
papacy isn't the pope now going to cop
28 yes the first time in person
uhhuh these have one mind and shall give
their power and strength unto the Beast
if you give your power and strength unto
the Beast you reject the stone yeah and
he is a stone of stumbling to you you
reject that he is the way that truth and
the life isn't that so that
unfortunately put you out of the Plan of
Salvation the papal church will never
relinquish her claim to
infallibility all that she has done in
her persecution of those who reject her
dogmas she holds to be right and would
she not repeat the same acts should the
opportunity be
presented let the restraints now imposed
by secular governments be removed and
Rome be reinstated in her former power
and there would speedily be a Revival of
her tyranny and
persecution has he not already said that
fundamentalists that believe the Bible
as it stands are a Bane and they should
be removed from society and he wants the
United Nations to have more teeth that
means to have more power with laws and
all of this so they want to get back
that power it's it's happening the Bible
says kiss the son as you be
destroyed not withstanding the
widespread declension of Faith there are
true followers of Christ in these
churches but the world over Longs for
something more than all of this hype and
ceremony and War of a decayed
infrastructure very well
put so there are people in many churches
and they're looking for the light in all
of this
darkness before the final visitation of
God's judgments upon the Earth there
will be among the people of the Lord a
Revival of primitive godliness not
witnessed since Apostolic times the
spirit of God will be poured out many
will separate from these churches in
which love of this world has supplanted
love for God and His word many ministers
and people people will gladly accept
those great truths which prepare a
people for the second coming Martin I
would M want to make an appeal to the
Christian churches get back to the roots
now now there's no other time like now
we are at the end our message hasn't
changed from what Peter said at
Pentecost and he accused the Jews that
they had persecuted and killed the
righteous one and we have to do the same
thing we have to tell the world that
this one that they rejected this Stone
of stumbling is the only way to
Salvation and then we can say he who
testifies these things says surely come
quickly amen even so come Lord Jesus we
are just before the coming of Christ
isn't now the time to embrace
him it's the there's no other time like
now the present no other time let's
pray Heavenly
Father the world is bent on
destruction they are running at
breathtaking speed towards the
precipice and you are holding out your
hands as you did to them 2,000 years ago
and saying come unto me all ye that
labor and I will give you
rest we are heavy laden we need that
rest help us to embrace us to embrace
the righteousness of Christ and to
accept that there is no other way to be
saved except by this Stone of stumbling
that was rejected 2,000 years ago and
that most would want to reject today
again again give us the wisdom and the
power of the Holy Spirit to make a right
decision is my prayer in Jesus name amen
[Music]
amen